وقلت لواء فايز انه لم يحدث اختراق على
الارض لكن الجيش السوداني يقول ان الايام
القادمه ستشهد انفراجا كبيرا في الاوضاع
على الارض هل هنالك مؤشرات على الارض لذلك
كنا نتحدث عن اللحظه التي نحن نتحدث بها
اي ماذا ماذا جرى على الارض
واكمل عبارتي قلت ان حتى في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم في منطقه الصحافات او في المدينه
الرياضيه والحديث قبل اسبوع عن بدع عمليات
التمشيط لم نعد نسمع عنها اي شيء لا بل
انطلقت المعارك واصبحت تاخذ بعدا اخر في
منطقه
دارفور غرب دارفور جنوب دارفور شرق دارفور
كردوفان الابيض عاصمه كردفان وبالتالي
هناك توسع في داره العمليات نعود الى
النقطه التي اثيرت هذه النقطه اعتقد ان
مرتكزها يعود الى يوم امس عندما تم الحديث
عن استقدام
تعزيزات من مناطق مختلفه وعرضت فيديوهات
لسيارات جيب عسكريه وسيارات نقل عسكريه
تحمل جنودا نعم اذا كانت هذه الاعداد
كافيه ومنظمه
وسيتم اعاده بنائها تحتاج الى يوم الى
يومين لغايه 48 ساعه تكون قد تم اعاده
تعييلها وادماجها
وادماج الاسلحه المختلفه بها لتكون مكتفيه
في اداره المعارك المحدوده نعم قد تحدث
ذلك لكن يبقى السؤال اين سيتم استخدامها
هل سيتم استخدامها في
عمليات التمشيط هل يتم استخدامها
لتنفيذ عمليات خاصه لانه هنا سؤال لابد ان
يطرح اين الحديث عن قوات التدخل السريع
التي اشار لها البرهان قبل انطلاق
العمليات وقال ان لديه ثلاثه الاف جندي من
السريع لم نسمع اي شيء عن هذه القوه وهذه
قوه خاصه هي هي المتخصصه في هذه يجري في
الخرطوم الان يعني يمكن ان يتطور ان لم
يكن تطور بالفعل الى حرب شوارع لكن سؤالي
عن ايضا عن سلاح الطيران الذي يوجد لدى
الجيش ولا يوجد لدى قوات الدعم السريعه
كيف استخدم حتى الان من بدايه هذه المعركه
لسيما وان الدعم السريع اتى بالفعل
بتعزيزات من مختلف الولايات الى الخرطوم
اين كان سلاح الطيران حينما كانت هذه
العربات الدفع الرباعي تسير مسافات طويله
الى الخرطوم
يا سيد يعني السؤال يعني اجابته دعني اجيب
في بعدين البعد الاول علينا ان نتحدث عن
القدرات لسلاح الجو السوداني وهو سلاح جو
متواضع يوجد اثنين طائره كلغه ارقام 37
طائره تقوم بدور العمليات الارضيه و42
طائره تقوم بدور العمليات الجويه اذا
ويمكن توظيف جزئيا للعمليات الارضيه اذا
هذه القدرات لكن السؤال مدى جاهزيتها مدى
تطورها قدراتها القتاليه
طبيعه التنظيم والتسليح بها هذه تعود الى
ستينيات وسبعينيات القرن الماضي وهي من
الطائرات التي خرجت من الخدمه في معظم
الدول وتستخدم المقاربات القديمه
قنابل ما يطلق عليها الجنرال بيرفس او
الاسقاط الحر وبالتالي لا يعني لا تستخدم
التقنيات او الذخائر الذكيه التي تعمل ضمن
نظام الجي بي اس هذه النقطه رقم واحد
النقطه رقم
ان السودان الان مليون وثمانم الف كيلو
متر مربع القوه قوات الدعم السريع منتشره
في العديد من المناطق منتشره في كوردفان
500 الف كيلو متر مربع في منطقه اسف
دارفور 500 الف كيلو متر مربع دارفور
بحدود 180 الف كيلو متر مربع اذا بقيه
المناطق الان عندما نتحدث عن حركه اليات
مدوده حركه سريعه
لمتابعتها تحتاج اولا قبل سلاح الجو الى
منظومه استخباريه
محكمه في اداء عملها تستطيع ان تزود
المعلومه وتصل المعلومه الى سلاح الجو
بالوقت المناسب وتكون الاستجابه ورد الفعل
في الوقت المناسب لانه هذه القوات تغير
تغير من اتجاهات حركتها بسرعه والامر
الاخر هذه اليات خفيفه حتى في حال قدوم
الطائرات مجرد سماعي هذا الصوت في الجو
تنتشر بسرعه وبالتالي تصبح عمليه
اليه او اليتين او عده اليات ولكن بقيه
الاليات من الصعوبه ان الطائره تلاحق
اليات تندفع في ارض مفتوحه او في ارض ذات
طيات ارضيه اذا دعني اقول سلاح الجو الان
تم توظيفه بصوره رئيسيه
لمعالجه الموقف الصعب في مدينه الخرطوم
لماذا لانه دخل اربعين الف جندي في عام
2019 تم تعزيز هذه القوات هذه القوات يعني
تعتبر نظريا جزء من الجيش وبالتالي تم
ايكال بعض المهام الها متواجدين حول
القياده العامه هناك كتيبه داخل المطار
متواجدين حول القصر الرئاسي وفجاه ظهرت في
عمليه عسكريه سيطرت على المقرات سيطرت
ولها معسكرات هنا بدات استخدام سلاح الجو
بقدراته المتاحه ضد الاهداف وضمن اولويات
معينه يعني دعني اقول لولا سلاح الجو
الوضع الميداني داخل مدينه الخرطوم اسوا
من الوضع الحالي بدراجه كبيره جدا بالنسبه
انا لا انكر دوره نعم نعم يعني لنكون
صريحين لو لم لولا سلاح الجو لكن نتحدث
بمقاربه مختلفه ما الذي يقوم به الان في
الخرطوم الخرطوم مدينه بها ثمانيه ملايين
بمدنيه ثلاث بها ثمانيه ملايين انسان
وسط الخرطوم منطقه مزدحمه فيها مقرات
ومناطق سياديه ما الذي يقدمه سلاح الجو في
هذه المعركه حول القياده العامه حول القصر
الجمهوري حول المطار ما الذي يمكن ان
يفعله السلاح الجو
يا سيدي هو ماذا يعني ماذا عمل وماذا يعمل
ماذا عمل هو تعامل مع العديد من المعسكرات
لقوات الرد السريع وهذه المعسكرات تم
تدميرها او تدمير جزء كبير منها تم تدمير
او الحاق لا اقول تدمير الحاق ضرر كبير
بمنظومه الامداد اللوجستيه خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالمحروقات والذخائر وما شابه ذلك
وبالتالي بدات تعاني قوات الرد السريع من
ذلك
الان دوره في المناطق الماهوله وباستنادا
الى طبيعه التسليح ستبقى محفوفه بالمخاطر
ويستخدم بحذر كبير حتى لانه الان الجيش
يعتبر هو يدافع عن الوطن يدافع عن امن
الوطن وبالتالي لا يجوز له ان يغامر في
الحاق اضرار اذا استخدامه اذا بتلاحظ
يسمع صوت الطائره يكون هناك دفاعات جويه
يبحث عن اهداف قد تكون لا تلحق الضرر في
حال مهاجمتها
بالسكان او بالبنيه التحتيه اذا هو يعمل
في اطار ضيق جدا ضمن قدراته وضمن المعطيات
على الارض وهذه المعطيات متغيره لماذا لان
هذه اليات الدفع الرباعي تنتقل من مكان
الى مكان وبالتالي هناك عمليه التعقب يجب
ان تكون استخباريه في الاول لانه سلاح
الجو عليه ان يتلقى المعلومه الناضجه التي
يستطيع التعامل معها شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه الاضاحات فايز الدويريه الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من عمان
[موسيقى]